let's say that we have four siblings
right over here and they're trying to
decide how to pick who should do the
dishes each night and so the oldest
sibling right over here he decides well
look I'll just put all of our names into
a into a bowl and then I'll just
randomly pick one of our names out of
the bowl each night and then that person
is going to be so this is the bowl right
over here and I'm just going to put four
sheets of paper in there each of them
it's going to have one of their names
and then he's just going to randomly
pick it out each night and then that's
the person who's going to do their
dishes so they all say well you know
that's that seems like a reasonable
reasonably fair thing to do and so they
start that process so let's say that
after the first three nights that he the
the oldest the oldest brother here and I
maybe let's call him let's call him
Bill let's say after three nights bill
has not had to do the dishes so at that
point the rest of siblings are starting
to think maybe just maybe something
fishy is happening so what I want to
think about is what is the probability
of that happening what's the probability
of three nights in a row bill does not
get picked if we assume that we were
randomly taking if bill was truly
randomly taking these things out of the
bowl and and not cheating in some way
what's the probability that that would
happen that three nights in a row bill
would not be picked I encourage you to
pause the video and think about that
well let's think about the probability
that Bill's not picked on a given night
if it's truly random so we're going to
assume we're going to assume that Bill's
not cheating so assume assume truly
random truly random and that each of the
sheets of paper have a one in four
chance of being picked what's the
probability that bill does not get
picked well there's so let me the
probability that nut I guess I'm right
this bill not picked on a night on a
night well there's four equally likely
outcomes and three of them result in
bill not getting picked so there's a
three-fourths probability
that bill is not picked on a given night
well what's the probability that Bill's
not picked it three nights in a row let
me write that down
so the probability bill not picked three
nights nights in a row well that's the
probabilities he's not picked on the
first night times the probability that
he's not picked on the second night
times the probability that he's not
picked on the third night so that's
going to be three to the third power or
3 times 3 times 3 so that's 27 over 4 to
the 3rd power 4 times 4 times 4 is 64
and if we want to express that as a
decimal so that is 27 I get my
calculator out that is 27 divided by 64
is equal to and I'll just round to the
nearest hundredth right here 0.42 so
that is equal to 0.42 and so this
doesn't seem that unlikely it's it's a
little less likely than kind of even
odds but it's not you know you wouldn't
you wouldn't question someone's
credibility if you know there's there's
a 42 percent roughly a 42 percent chance
that three nights in a row bill would
not be picked so this this seems like if
you're assuming truly random that that
it's a reasonable your hypothesis that
it's truly random seems seem you know
there's a good chance that that you're
right it's a 40 there's a 42 percent
chance you would have the outcome you
saw if your assumption is true but let's
say let's say you keep doing this and
you trust your older brother you know
why why would he want to cheat out his
his younger siblings but let's say that
Bill's not picked 12 nights in a row
so then everyone's starting to get
everyone's starting to get a little bit
suspicious suspicious with Bill with
Bill right over here and so they say
well you know well we're going to give
him the benefit of doubt assuming that
that he's being completely honest that
this is completely random process what
is the açaí that he would not be picked
nights in a row well just just write
that down
so the probability bill and it's really
the same stuff that I just wrote up here
I'll just read bill not picked 12 nights
in a row well that's going to be three
you're going to take 12 3 4 it's and
multiply them together it's going to be
3/4 to the 12th power and what is this
going to be equal to well let's see if
you take well 3/4 says I'll just write 3
divided by 3/4 which is going to be 0.75
to the 12th power now this is a much
smaller this is now if we actually this
is going to be 0.3 I guess we could go
to it we could go to one more decimal
place here 0.32 or we could say so I
mean it's this is zero point zero point
zero three two I should say which is
equal to so this is approximately equal
to let me write that which is equal to
three point two percent so now you have
every right to start thinking that
something is is getting fishy you could
say well look you know if there was and
this is what statisticians actually do
they often just define a threshold and
hey you know if the probability of this
happening purely by chance is is more
than 5% then I'll say well maybe it was
happening by chance but if the
probability of this happening purely by
chance was way no and and this is the
threshold of statisticians often use is
5% but that's somewhat arbitrarily
defined but this is a fairly low
probability that it would happen fairly
by chance so you might be tempted to
reject the hypothesis to reject the
hypothesis that it was truly random that
bill is cheating in some way and you
could imagine if it wasn't 12 in a row
was 20 in a row then this probability
becomes really really really really
really small and and so your hypothesis
that it's truly random starts to really
come and come into doubt